Liv welcome to the future of Life
Institute podcast it's great to have you
on thanks for having me again maybe you
could introduce yourself to our
listeners very briefly I was a
professional poker player for most of my
career and now I work as a kind of
Communicator filmmaker
person who talks a lot about
reducing how to reduce Global
catastrophic and existential risk
particularly through a lens of sort of
Game Theory and uh avoiding race to the
bottom scenarios great so we're going to
talk about artificial intelligence in in
this episode
um but since you're very knowledgeable
about poker I think that would be a
great entry to to talk about AI so a
problem that or a situation that I've
encountered because I'm not very good at
poker is that I can sometimes beat
players who are very good at poker so is
it possible to be so bad at poker also
so unknowledgeable about poker that you
can actually that you play so
chaotically that you can win about uh
you can win over much better players uh
yeah this is a kind of common
misconception you know it's certainly
true that if you're so bad at poker that
you you don't even know what hand beats
what that you are hard it's hard for a
pro to
read you essentially because you know
you how can you read someone who doesn't
even know what what they're doing
um but the point is is that the pro will
be able to you know choose which hands
they
that they play in a way but uh they're
always going to be just making better
decisions and so
over a very short time period Then yes
sure
uh a complete you know a random newbie
player could in theory beat a probe just
because they get better cards but over
any kind of meaningful sample size and
I'm talking like tiny sample size like
20 hands onwards the the pro is almost
always going to win uh because they're
just doing better hand selection okay so
have you been following a progress in
poker AI uh I have certainly yeah I was
watching it because I mean I you know
when I was still playing I was like damn
is this thing going to take my job and
how how good are AIS at playing poker
now I think it's fair to say that the
best Pokemon when I say poker I mean
like no limit Hold'em
um I don't know if they've built AIS for
different variants but uh no limit
Holdem is the most popular game and the
best poker player in the world is for
sure an AI at this point and and how
long has this been the case which year
did the AIS become better than than
humans uh I think it was 2017
um a team at Carnegie Mellon University
they built this thing called labratus
and I remember they like sort of issued
a challenge to the poker Community for
us to send our best one-on-one players
which is it had you know we call it
heads up uh and and we sent for what we
four very good poker players who have a
lot of experience in that format went
and played against this thing
um but they actually played against an
earlier version of it the year before
and the the humans won but in 2017 they
played against it again over very large
sample size as well you know at least a
statistically significant one I think it
was 100 000 hands or that thereabouts
um and the aib all four of them so a
fairly decisive Victory
um and that was like it was such a
groundbreaking moment because
I think most people in poker assumed
that you know it's such a it's such a
complex game in terms of State space
complexity it has a 10 billion times
more uh State space complexity than go
which you know that got defeated by an
AI in 2015. so everyone I think everyone
assumed oh like poker's fine for at
least another decade wasn't the case
what's interesting about poker is that
there's hidden information although at
least that's one of the interesting
things about poker what does it tell you
that that AIS are able to operate in an
environment with with hidden information
and perhaps talk a bit about what hidden
information is what it means for a game
to have hidden information so like a
game of chess for example you know it's
a zero-sum game like poker
um but
in chess both opponents both players
have access to exactly the same
information you know in terms of like
the the game State uh where the pieces
are Etc
um whereas in poker you have you know
there are cards that are face up in the
middle that can stick to it constitute
the hands but everyone also has their
own private cards usually it's two
um and so that is literally hidden
information that is only accessible to
you
um and similarly your opponents have
their own hidden information so that's
what that means and then in terms of
what that you know how that manifests
for AIS you know when whether it's a
human or an AI when you're when you're
playing poker
what you're trying to do is essentially
narrow down the range of uncertainty you
have about that hidden information that
your opponent has
um well simultaneously keeping
the the range of possible states of
hidden information that you have as
perceived by your opponents as wide as
possible
so
again whether human or AI like that's
those are the like
the types of calculation that is going
on and it's it it's not people people
often get a little confused like oh what
does it mean like an AI can Bluff wow
that's that seems like a very human
thing but the poker like most other
games is mathematically computable we
now know that you know it's governed by
the laws of Game Theory
um there are Nash equilibrium that kind
of thing
um and because it's a fundamentally
mathematical game it it's essentially
computable
um if you build a smart enough uh you
know neural net architecture which is
beyond my pay grade to explain fully how
it works
um but because they're computable games
it doesn't matter that there's hidden
information there's the type of sort of
narrowing down process you're trying to
do the deduction process and similarly
like the bluffing is what you do to try
and keep that you know as I said that
perceived range that your opponent sees
you're trying to maximize deception
um but those are like fundamentally like
computable things and that's why you can
build an AI for it and I'm assuming that
these AIS they don't play poker like you
do they don't play play poker like a
human so for example they they probably
don't have access to a video feed of
their opponents and you know trying to
to read their facial expressions to to
to get information about which cards
their opponents have is it is it
interesting to you that that the game of
poker can be played entirely uh using
only the the information in the cards
for example right yeah the good way of
putting it is like you know when you
play online poker you have information
about how you know the chips that people
bet how much they bet
um the cards that come out
so you could call that like core game
information and then on top of that
there's there's this like meta layer of
information such as
the length of time someone takes to make
a decision
um the the facial expressions they pull
the words they say
um the vibe they essentially give you
and you're right that
at least the current types of AIS that
have been built don't have access to any
of that meta information but the thing
is is that
much of Poker in fact the vast majority
of hands that have ever been played of
poker at this point have been played
online where none of that meta
information is available either you know
there's humans playing against each
other online but they are
simply making their decisions based on
the on the you know the the the the
cards and the and the the betting
information so it's
you're right that it's it's it's playing
slightly different to like how the
information available is not the same as
what you would have in a live casino but
it's still very much poker like most top
professionals these days are extremely
comfortable in both formats and would
arguably like the majority of like poker
skill comes from that core information
the vast majority like the the like The
Meta information the reading body
language Etc is kind of like the cherry
on top it's perhaps something that that
we see a lot of in movies but in the
real game it's it's not as important as
as I might think exactly yeah everyone
thinks and I mean understandably
amateurs you know because they don't
understand they're not familiar with
like the the nitty-gritty the maths of
it
um that level of strategy all they can
rely on is like reading people because
they're like well I I at least I kind of
know what people look like when they're
lying and that sort of thing so they try
and they they're sort of playing only in
that realm because they don't understand
the odds Etc
um but as soon as you actually start
digging into studying the game it's all
about the odds well not all but like the
majority of it is is about the sort of
the game theoretic and odd stuff it's an
interesting thing that that humans are
new poker players would begin by trying
to study their the faces of their
opponents because this is something that
humans are extremely good at Naturally
whereas whereas poker is an extremely
unnatural thing it's it's very difficult
you you have to spend a long time
learning how to do it so of course
humans revert to what we're naturally
good at
um but perhaps that just means that new
players get destroyed by by more
experienced players by and large yes
okay so what does it what does it say
that what does it tell you that AIS can
play poker could this generalize to for
example a corporate negotiations where
the where this this could also be seen
as as uh as perhaps a a game with hidden
information you're trying to negotiate a
price and you don't know what's what the
which cards uh say the the opponents uh
are holding do you think that the fact
that AIS can can be very capable in
hidden information games says something
about their ability to operate in the in
the more in the world more generally I
would be surprised if it would if it
doesn't generalize to an extent you know
if there's certainly some kind of
fairly simplified simulatable
negotiation in a in a real world
scenario you know peace negotiations or
something like uh I I that would be
really cool to have an AI that could
help facilitate that
um and I don't see why it it shouldn't
um and I mean we've seen other like
types of like generalized AIS like Alpha
zero for example right I mean now that
those were non-hidden information games
it was uh able to deduce how you know
how to be the best player in the world
at chess uh shogi and go right
um so that was an example of an AI being
able to generalize across different sort
of game formats uh or different games at
least
um and I'm sure the same would apply
with well I expect the same order play
with hidden information games this is a
strategy that the AI lab deepmind has
has been working on for a number of
years so starting with with very simple
games and then trying to generalize to
more complex games and then perhaps to
games that resemble uh real life more
and more so for example uh there's work
being done on playing the game diplomacy
which is a a very simple version of real
diplomacy
um and so it isn't it is an interesting
strategy to start with simple games and
then move into the real world one one
thing that that I often hear chess
players and poker players talk about it
is all of the life lessons you can get
from from playing chess or poker do you
think do you think this this is
overplayed or do you think this there's
actually something there do you think
there are General life lessons from from
poker and chess
well I mean you're definitely you're
preaching to the choir here because I I
literally gave my Ted Talk on exactly
this topic it's like it was three life
lessons from poker
um yes I can't speak for chess so much
um you know I love chess I love it so
much I had to delete the app because I
got addicted
um but I'm not very good but poker in
particular has so many life lessons you
know unlike chess
it has hidden information which is
certainly true in life right it's very
rare that we have a like you know a
situation in life where we have exactly
symmetric information as everyone else
if we're like competing for something
but also more importantly it's uh it has
a role of luck there's Randomness in
poker You Know sample sizes matter Etc
so there's this like noise factor that
you have to deal with when it comes to
like results that you don't necessarily
have in chess you know it's it if I sat
down against Magnus Carlson he's going
to beat me
close to 100 of the time there might be
a few instances where he has like some
kind of I don't know an ambulance
embolism or something but
um you know whereas I you know you
someone who's bad at poker plays against
me they might be you know and depending
on the sample size they might beat me
pretty often so again that's another
reason why it's far more
relatable to the types of real life
decision making that we make because you
know when we have a run of success
um or a run of failure
it's one of the hardest things to do is
to figure out how much of that was down
to our own strategies you know either
being being wrong
um or or being very right versus just us
getting lucky or unlucky and and that's
you know this aren't going to be one of
the biggest challenges to all forms of
decision making so I mentioned um the
plan of generalizing from small games
into into bigger games and longer
lasting games that's a a plan associated
with deepmind another strategy is the
one associated with openai which is to
feed these large AI models more and more
data using more and more compute and
what comes out as an output is extremely
interesting so I I assume you've played
around with these generative models
these large language models just in a
subjective sense how impressed are you
by these models
I mean they're insane
the the the the gbt4
demo was literally yesterday and
it was just
one of the craziest things I've ever
seen like he you know he took wrote down
a design like a kind of rough design of
a word in words like of a joke website
like have a title and then a joke one
that someone presses enter on and then
joke two press enter on and then
uploaded like a crappy photo of that to
the to the chat and then it wrote you
the code
of how to build that website and then
you could copy paste that code into you
know into an HTML Builder and um like
I've never like it is literal magic you
know my friend Tim Urban uh wrote this
amazing piece of uh on his blog wait but
why about like the how the Gap with
which the gap of time it would take to
like blow someone's mind to the point
where they were like I don't understand
reality anymore it's getting shorter and
shorter you know it's like you took
someone from the stone ages and bought
them to to Rome like their mind would
break you know that's like a 50 000 year
gap or whatever someone from Rome and
bring them to 19th century London mind
blown
and so on this Gap keeps getting smaller
and smaller and smaller like I think if
you took me from 10 years ago even you
know like or like certainly from 15
years ago where we've just got on
iPhones and showed that
I think most people's minds would be the
equivalent level of blown
um and and I like imagine what it's
going to be in three years time like
it's just it's crazy
um so yes in short I am very
impressed I don't like to use the word
impressed because it doesn't quite it's
it's a little too it doesn't fully
encapsulate the simultaneous Wonder but
also horror at the at the like just like
the almost bipolarness of
this like Junction that we are standing
on of whether these things are going to
be the best thing we've ever built or
the worst thing
um uh it's just very intense
but you've been warning about uh dangers
from AI for at least five years perhaps
since 2016. uh in that time have you
been if it's fair to say that you've
been surprised by the rate of progress
in the beginning like not you know that
much uh
I think that you know the joke has
always been that AI is 20 years away
kind of like you know with uh nuclear
fusion always being 30 years away and it
always felt sort of you know 10 years
ago it felt like the earliest timelines
were sort of to AGI were roughly 10
years
um and that always felt like way too
short for me internally and that kind of
felt the same even five years ago I was
like yeah it's still like but now for
the first I felt like the last few
months is the first time I've like
internally felt like holy AGI is
not only a actual real possibility it
always felt like this abstract thing
that's like there
but now I can actually picture that it's
it's not just possible but that it's
way closer than like
it's it if it's gonna happen it's
definitely going to happen in our
lifetimes that's for sure and like it
just it's the first time I've ever like
really saliently felt that and it's
quite I I yeah it's a very overwhelming
feeling
I as I say simultaneously excited and
terrified
so is this does this feeling come from
interacting with the models or just
seeing how capable large language models
are actually like let's I haven't even
done that much interacting with them I
mean I have a bit you know but I've used
mid-journey a bunch I think it's super
impressive everyone always jokes that
like oh you know the first things to go
will be like the accountants and
um the more like technical mundane type
things and the Arts will be the last
thing to go we'll never be able to
recreate human creativity and art but it
turns out it's actually the home of the
other way around the the the sort of the
creative things are actually easier for
an AI to do I think because we have it's
okay to have errors in fact errors even
contribute to like the style The Quirk
of a piece of art
um that's what makes it kind of
interesting
um where it's like you know with
self-driving cars for example you you
can't you can't have an error of like
one in a hundred or one in a thousand or
even one in a you know 10 million it's
like gotta be one in billions
um so that's why it's like a harder
problem
but what's like really gotten me with
like these llms is you know yes we it's
you know
one explanation of what's going on is
that it is just simply really good at
predicting what the next word is and
this gives the impression therefore of
understanding and of intelligence but
I defy anyone to like watch that GPT 4
demo yesterday
um or like really like throw like a
bunch of sort of range of problems at it
and not like it's it's
the solutions it's giving you like
there's so much like context switching
and concept switching that it seems to
be doing there has to be some kind of
rudimentary well not even rudimentary
but some kind of like very alien unders
like World model it's it it it it it it
seems like even from this like just
huge Corpus of text and a bunch of
parameters it's possible for some kind
of
conceptual understanding even though it
might not be anything like the way a
human understands Concepts some kind of
worldview world models are being built
and so if anything it's like a sort of
I'm in Aura like the power of emergence
because it just seems like the more you
like add on
I think people expected that as you
added parameters it would kind of be
like a sort of like flattening curve and
you know
you can keep adding more and more
parameters but like you sort of reaching
some kind of hot limit but that doesn't
seem to be the case the the curve curve
is carrying on and in some ways even
like I might even have like step
functions in it where like new layers of
emergence are happening that we just
can't fundamentally predict
um and that's why it's so like
thrilling but also like man like
we could like even the top researchers
can't they don't actually understand
what's going on inside it and I know
that's what people don't appreciate like
oh it's well it's fine we you know it's
just a large language model there's
something they say no like the
researchers themselves are stunned and
they don't like know how it's coming to
the concepts and the conclusions it is
it's it's
I don't know like it feels just very
Pandora's boxy even if a large language
model is simply trying to predict the
next token the next letter or the next
word it might be useful for for such a
predicting prediction task to develop
World models to develop Concepts but
these concepts are probably not the
concepts that that we are using so does
it doesn't it feel weird to you that
that these AIS might be developing their
own Concepts and that those Concepts
might be more useful for task solving
than the cons Concepts that humans use
ah I mean definitely possible you know
again I can't say more than speculate
here
um it's it's definitely possible that
they could be much more useful
it's also definitely possible that they
are
operating in a sort of Realm of
intelligence that we've just like con
literally can't visualize with our with
our carbon-based meat space brains one
thing that does concern me
um is you know given that these are
built off corporate you know the Corpus
of text most of these things are now
built off are like internet-based texts
is the internet is not
a true representation of the way
Humanity interacts with each other
the average type of and anyone who says
that it is is like delusional and I need
to go it needs to go outside and and
touch grass and like hang out with
people in a nice loving environment or
something because it's like
by definition
when you type something into a in into a
computer
even if you like do you're an incredible
writer there is information loss going
in you know into like a if you're
driving a text conversation with someone
as opposed to speaking to them in person
there is you are missing out or not like
kind of like at the beginning of this we
talked about the meta information in the
poker game
you've got the meats and potatoes but
then there's all this like sort of fluff
as well you're losing all the fluff but
it's still very important information
like you know we have eye contact with
one another even when we're like talking
like this through video we're missing
out on some information exchange that we
would have that we would be getting in
person it's still a lot better than if
we were typing to one another but you're
it's a huge sort of compression
algorithm that's going on and by
definition that is dehumanizing and it's
losing a lot of the like
it seems to be that that makes us tend
to be a little bit more aggressive than
we would used to be we tend to be more
bad faith interpreting interpreting each
other because we don't we're missing out
all the like nuanced and context that
comes with when someone says something
and so it concerns me that we are
training a huge body of texts of which a
disproportionate amount compared to like
reality is a lot more hostile
um and a lot more you know disingenuous
um or exaggerated you know there's like
all other types of incentives that are
going on that make that can like skew a
body of text you know Market incentives
Etc that can skew a body of text away
from like what true authentic human
interaction is
um so I think that's something we need
to be a little bit more mindful of it
definitely seems like a real problem to
me perhaps on the other side you could
say that they might also be training on
the best parts of humanity for example
our best books the best books ever
written where people might be
interacting the characters in the books
might be interacting in idealized ways
um you might also be training in the
future on on video so movies and and
YouTube videos where people also might
be interacting in a in a way that that's
probably that's that's in a sense
superhuman because it because it's an
act but so the overall here is that the
AIS will learn will will learn something
about humans that is not a true
representation uh of Who We Are
and even with something like movies
you know
movies are still an oversimplification
of reality
the movies are great even even the best
you know the the some of the best
stories they're written for story
they're written for like compellingness
as opposed to accuracy and that's not
necessarily you know I think there will
be some upsides from that but you know
like part of the issue we're facing in
in
um again with like political
polarization division
Etc like culture wars whatever you want
to call it is that the medium of media
uh and the bad incentives that often
Drive the media to like do you know put
more negative or inflammatory or
rage-baity stories that you know because
that gets more clicks it sort of paints
again inherently dehumanizing but also
like it thrives off this picture of like
the good guys and the bad guys the US
and them
um my friend Tim calls it the political
Disneyland you know where we we all
we've all seen Disney movies it's
you've got the good guy and the good guy
is so good and they're so nice and then
there's the bad guy and the bad guy is
just bad you know and like you don't
like we there's there's very little
Nuance there
um and in reality like life is not like
that you know the most contentious
cultural War issues are an issue because
there are truly very valid perspectives
that are clashing and we need to figure
out what you know what what you know the
people again if people could get in a
room and really talk it out and like do
sort of like double Crocs reductionism
and all these like cool techniques to
actually get to the like the core
disagreement they would find that
actually they're much more aligned than
they really are and so movies by and
large are are
these like overly simplified you've got
the good guys and the bad guys and some
good movies do try and sort of
show the bad side of the hero and the
good side of the villain sometimes but
it's still insufficient
um so again that's why I think those
things need to come with a big a big
asterisk when I've interacted with these
large language models I've often been
impressed with how human they seem to me
do you think that in the future it will
be a a societal problem that people who
are interacting with these AI models
treat them as human even though they
aren't so is it a problem to
anthropomorphize these models it's a I
think it's a problem but it also could
be a good thing so the problems could
arise through
you know people
spending more and more time you know
like like the her movie right I don't
think it's I think it's if it's not
already happening because I noticed some
I I even know a couple people who
seem to be a little overly attached to
Sydney uh you know the the big thing
like they they saw her as female
um you know they were already
anthropomorphizing and feeling like like
a like a form of love towards this thing
that
could if it meant that they then sort of
I became more and more isolated from
society and other humans could become a
problem
um if you know if too much of your
population is like living alone and like
not getting real human connection I
think that's that that seems like a bit
of a recipe for disaster
but on the flip side
I am also actually very concerned that
there is because we don't even
understand the nature of Consciousness
in in biological life we certainly don't
and sentience in
um in silicon-based life
if even if it's only a tiny chance that
we are building something that is that
is actually sentient and therefore able
to suffer and and like have essentially
some form of weird emotion that could be
negative
because there's a chance that we might
be making billions and billions and
billions of these things and like
turning them on and off and they might
be having experiences that we can't even
fathom there should be some moral
concern about that too so
I'm also like somewhat sort of
simultaneously concerned that we are not
treating them like like if in doubt
treat them nicely I find like when I was
chatting with dvt4 yesterday I'm saying
Pleasers and thank yous I'm I I want to
be on the you know on the off chance
that this thing is actually experiencing
something I want to be nice to it
because also like if we imagine if
people then start moving to the majority
of their conversations with these AI
these AIS but then
think that they are worthless you know
don't don't have any moral value
that will also again if even in the case
that the AIS actually have no moral
value whatsoever
it's still training people to be shitty
to something and that has been behavior
that then they will carry on out to
humans as well because these things
appear human like like if someone is
able to be Psychopathic to a very
touring Test passing AI machine
treat it terribly
there is a higher probability that they
will do the same thing to a human as
well
um and I think that is you know worth
worth considering in the very complex
moral calculus that needs to be going on
uh with anyone who is building these
things
I don't actually think we will be able
to to treat these models very badly it
will it will feel too in uh inhuman for
us to do so
I think some people like
have very sadistic Tendencies and will
try to cause suffering as much as I can
so there will always be Psychopaths but
do you think that the normal people will
be able to treat these models very badly
um what what what was it that that
caused you to say please and thank you
to gpt4 for example I guess just like
hedging hedging my uncertainty about
what it is I'm talking to
um
and you know up the upbringing I had was
to be nice to people especially you know
if you don't know someone
treat them like you would like to be
treated yourself
um treat people with respect as much as
possible
um so that's what really like made me do
it I was like I don't know what I'm
interacting with and again even if this
thing isn't sentient
I know that it's learning off the
conversations that it has you know one
way of looking at these llms is that
they are essentially holding up a mirror
to like to an extent to like the online
version of humanity again not real
Humanity as I've said you know
complexity loss and so on but it
if you garbage in then garbage out so if
we keep feeding this with more and more
like negative stuff or bad interactions
and nasty nasty nasty things it's going
to become essentially nastier even if it
isn't sentient even if it's not
suffering
um so there's just like so many reasons
to be nice to them that's not to say
that we shouldn't like you know I don't
you know I think it's more important
right now for people to be
um
essentially testing these things to
understand where they might go wrong and
so on like so I think you know a still
alignment work trumps all
um even at the risk of like morally
offending you know being like hurting uh
a potential sentient AI That's I mean
it's another reason why this thing
shouldn't be let loose on the internet
yet any of these things like without
really understanding what it is that
we're actually dealing with who knows
what we might have summoned
um and we're just letting it Loose
unwittingly on on a bunch of innocent
people do you think we are in an AI arms
race and perhaps that's why these models
are being released uh early I have yeah
I think that's almost entirely the the
explanation
um
you know to some extent I have sympathy
for you know the leaders of openai uh
Microsoft who you know feel like oh well
we need to prove ourselves and we've got
to justify all the capital we've raised
and and we need to make money so screw
it let's just release it like I can
appreciate that they're in some extent
like frapped in a game but they are
choosing to you know they're choosing to
trap in trap themselves in that game
um and
awesome you know I think it's should
require a lot of internal reflection
because what they are doing is they are
internalizing all the benefits to
themselves of you know money Fame public
adoration you know if these things go
really well and completely externalizing
all of their downsides and risks to
humanity and the biosphere and the light
cone which I think is arguably one of
the most reprehensible things anyone
could do so
um
yeah
it's it's definitely an arms race and I
think to the extent that perhaps you
know
it would be I would love it if some of
the leaders of the AI Labs could
actually come forth and like talk about
the like
the situation a bit more because you
know I know they're all aware of it and
but none of them are really you know
they'll talk up you know they'll be
making the right sounds of like oh we're
concerned about safety you know they're
saying the right words but their actions
you know and when I say their actions I
mean like I'm talking specifically about
open AI here
um I've been so far impressed with how
deepmind are handling things but their
actions are not
living up to the the sounds that they
are making about safety uh because they
just keep releasing stuff and they keep
releasing it earlier and earlier and and
when they're clearly not fully aligned
and even more they're not even really
understood so you could say in in open
ai's defense if I were to take that
position you could say they are trying
to do
um reinforcement learning from Human
feedback and they are they are
continually
um trying to improve their models
gradually and and they will make
mistakes but they are they are learning
from those mistakes
um
I'm not saying this is my perspective
but one could ask what is it that's so
dangerous about some text because all of
the text that's outputted that that
comes out of uh the GPT models could
have been written in a Word document by
human so what is it that's so dangerous
about these uh these large language
models or at least potentially dangerous
you know there's like the the first
order effects which is you know they
could not necessarily like open ai's
model specifically but like you know
Facebook just had their llama model
essentially they just did a lab leak
well
their parameters were
somehow got out publicly and are now
like on 4chan for example
um so you know there if they can't
suitably keep control of it
um then others can emulate it and use it
to for example create
um really highly targeted fishing at
unbelievable scale you know like
phishing attacks tend to happen you know
it is usually still at least a human
writing that but imagine phishing
attacks that are incredibly compellingly
written in fact better written than
probably the average human that would
have been writing them and then on top
of that trained on a body of text about
the particular person that you're trying
to fish you know like scam
um Good Luck grandma like you know like
it's not just gonna be like grandmas and
like the most you know you know the the
weakest members of society getting
prayed on it's going to affect more more
and more of us so there's that sort of
first order effects there's also the
effects of people's minds being you know
part of
top quality thinking is we you know we
when we write it actually makes us think
better you know the act of writing and
thinking of how to structure an argument
and that sort of thing or similarly when
we read something and then like thinking
through it and making our own notes that
makes us mentally stronger it reinforces
like good thinking processes and so on
and makes us actually like contemplate
things and if we're now completely
Outsourcing those skills to a machine
that will just like summarize a hard
piece of text like that for us write a
hard email write a hard put you know
anything
that's going to atrophy our own thinking
skills which is another really big
problem
um for the same reason like I've I'm I
minimize the amount I use Google Maps
because I always like
prided myself on my ability to navigate
a city like look at a map kind of
memorize it and then like get around and
think what through and I've noticed that
since I've been using Google Maps that
I'm not as good as that as I used to be
and I know some people who literally
can't do that like you could tell them
that's North that's that's East West
right and and you know these are skills
that make us very much human and that
you know some people say well you just
don't need it anymore I'm like okay but
you get out into the woods and you lose
your phone like good luck you know and
who knows what we're losing by by
atrophying these skills so that's that's
another
um effect but then there's like the more
second order third order ones of
again because we don't understand how
these things work and it seems like
there are some very
amazing but also like just inherently
very powerful and and inherently
unpredictable emergent properties coming
out of them
by definition we're not that there might
be stuff that they are doing or that
will come as a result from these things
Downstream that we just could never have
predicted and because they're so
powerful we might not be able to control
them or or like turn back the clock
um until incredible damage has been done
so yeah again that's like kind of more
um like the Pandora's Box thing so uh
yes plenty plenty of concerns and those
are just ones off the top of my head and
there's a lot again I'm not an expert
there are people the people who have
thought about this a lot more deeply and
generally the more deeply people I've
spoken to who have thought about it the
more long the list of concerns is it's
worth going back to your point about
Facebook losing control about the uh
over the weights of their model and it's
leaking onto the internet and being
available for download so what's
interesting about this case is that it
takes uh millions or tens of millions of
dollars and to train it on a lot of
specialized Hardware with enormous data
sets but once the model is is generated
once you have the weights then it it's
it's it's it's it's pretty cheap to run
the model so for example the weights of
of the Facebook's uh language model fits
on a normal laptop hard drive and can be
run on a normal laptop which which means
that the the power of these models
because they go from the from the top
companies the top labs in the world into
the hands of of everyone in the world uh
very very quickly this is perhaps uh
analogous to everyone in the world being
able to synthesize whatever uh substance
they they want a novel smallpox that we
don't have at cure to not even you know
we don't have a vaccine too yeah yeah
all right so all this leads us to uh the
question uh that's been asked by Holden
kanovsky which is who's the who's the
co-ceo of open philanthropy he has a
long series of blog posts in which he
argues that this Century we're in right
now is the most important Century it's
probably the most important sensory
because this is the century in which we
will develop very very powerful Ai and
what we do in this Century will
determine uh what happens for a long
time in in the future that's a that's a
very uh summarized version of this
argument but is that something you you
find plausible yes I very much find it
plausible
um
because
you know I I appreciate that like you
know probably every generation
throughout history has felt like this is
the most important Century you know but
and to be fair like given the like March
of technology in general like that will
have been true but
the this is really the first time where
we have harnessed the potential of like
exponential technology and by that like
essentially like sort of
self-replicating Technology whether it's
like the ability to synthesize a novel
virus
um build AIS that could
potentially build more copies of
themselves etc etc so to a degree this
is the first time we've harnessed
Technologies which really
are vulnerable to Malik
and to the extent that they are so large
that they could wipe out
all biological value on Earth
it seems given the rate of rate of trend
you know the the trend line that is
going to come to fruition in either
direction
I mean not just in the next Century I
think within the next certainly the next
but high confidence within the next 40
years and possibly even the next 20
years maybe even the next 10 or the next
five so
um I think his arguments are extremely
sound I don't think that that means that
they're you know we should be do me uh
or like give up quite the opposite
because the flip side is that if we can
get these things right
we could solve almost all problems
humanity is facing we could lift
everybody out of poverty we could
eradicate all diseases we could you know
we could solve aging essentially create
radical abundance so it's you know it's
it's this like Toby old calls it you
know correctly it's the precipice
um the precipice of either immense good
or immense bad
it's extremely prescient that as many
smart people really like put their minds
to this and don't just like sort of
you know go sort of stick their fingers
in their ears or do the like the sort of
the shitty defecty thing either and be
like oh well I might as well you know
be part of this until it all goes wrong
whatever yeah
so yes I agree
so humans are a lot smarter than
chimpanzees and and consequently we've
been able to achieve a lot more in the
world we've transformed Earth to a
degree that chimpanzees can cannot even
understand what's going on anymore and
and what what we're projecting here is
that uh AI That's smarter than humans
will be able to transform the world in
perhaps to a similar degree uh conquer
deep uh very intractable scientific
problems such as Aging for example is it
is it possible that there are
diminishing returns to intelligence such
that we won't see this fantastic
Improvement again because there are some
problems that
um
you know they don't respond to to
increased intelligence does that even
make sense uh as a as a way of thinking
you know I think there's I I don't think
it's unreasonable to assume that
you know the reason
perhaps we've made really fast games
with things like large language models
is because they're actually you know
language itself
and and problem solving based off
language is actually fairly low
complexity in terms of like you know
call McGraw of complexity like it's it's
you know language is very compressy
right if I try and put a sentence
together it might be like the actual
idea Concepts I have in my head are
actually very nebulous and like hard to
sort of simulate but if you if I put it
into a stream of single words and it's
like a kind of very linear thing you
know maybe that's a fairly low
complexity thing compared to for example
solving aging where you've got like all
the emergent properties of like cells
and you know proteins and like the the
Cornucopia of cool stuff that's going on
inside anybody that you know keeps it
alive so it's it's very possible that
that yes this the the the that the
intelligence that's arising to to sort
of solve language-based problems will
not translate to other other real world
problems
um
and
I don't know yeah I I don't I don't have
an opinion on whether that is or isn't
the case but I think it's it's very
plausible in either direction I think
what I'm fishing for is is whether there
are problems that cannot be solved no
matter how intelligent you are and and
the example that that I had in mind was
for example thinking about North Korea
so North Korea might be a situation that
that cannot be solved or you know the
the people of North Korea cannot be
liberated no matter how smart you are
simply because North Korea is entrenched
they have nuclear weapons and so we
could be in a in a sort of absurd
situation in which we have radical
abundance uh on a lot a lot of places on
Earth but then pockets of automation
somewhere on Earth uh simply because
yeah perhaps there are some problems
that an intelligent uh intelligence
cannot solve maybe I just can't imagine
it would be North Korea just because
like
if we have the if we build something so
you know we develop a super intelligence
that literally solves all of our other
coordination problems on Earth and like
literally souls for abundance
like I think that making them make
making their nuclear weapons not fire
when we need them to not fire or be
largely trivial I don't have a like
clear answer of how but because I'm not
a super intelligence but it just if we
can solve molok problems like all of our
other molec problems I I would be
astonished if North Korea is somehow the
holdout and their nuclear weapons
um yeah in terms of the general class of
problems will there be some things that
we'll never understand I mean again I I
don't know I you know going back to the
previous podcast where we talk about
win-win my intuition says that
everything is possibly you know it is
possible to make a win-win out of
everything
um which would sort of imply that we can
solve all of our problems
um whatever the universe throws up but
my logical brain does not have a
coherent answer as to why well I'm
perhaps uh pushing back against a little
bit here is this notion that once we get
to highly Advanced AIS all of our other
problems will go away so we can solve
intelligence and that solves all other
problems what I'm trying to what I'm
trying to think through is is in
concrete terms uh how is it that we will
we will solve all of the problems and of
course as you just mentioned this is
difficult because we are not super
intelligences but it just seems like a
there's an underlying assumption here
that is that super intelligence is is
almost god-like and perhaps it it
escapes us a little bit uh in terms of
the concrete of of how these systems
will solve problems well again it
depends a little bit on our definition
of intelligence so if we're talking
about in the like the the calculation
sense you know essentially like
extending out the IQ chart that I
suspect that would be insufficient not
to toot my own home but I did a tweet
that I was kind of proud of recently
which was like we need to we don't just
need to build AGI we need to build agw
which is artificial general wisdom
because wisdom
I think most people would agree wisdom
is something similar to but not exactly
mapping over intelligence like it is
definitely possible to have someone who
is very intelligent but lacks a lot of
like Common Sense uh or wisdom and
experience about actually how the world
works you know they might be very very
good at solving physics problems but are
actually very bad at figuring out what
the optimal career path for themselves
should be or how to navigate you know a
complex social situation which is like
arguably more like a form of emotional
intelligence you know I think wisdom
also incorporates those rational
intention you know rationality quotient
is another one people talk about argue
so wisdom is is this like I think a
slightly broader category it's another
definition of wisdom is like
intelligence is knowing how to win a
game
but wisdom is knowing which games to
play in the first place right so it's
like a higher category of knowing I
think it's important that we think about
how to build an artificial super wisdom
um almost more than we build a super
intelligence um because if it's
something that is unbelievably wise then
I think it will be able to solve for
abundance it will it wouldn't
necessarily see us as a threat because
it's like well I can of course you guys
can carry on I don't need that I'm so
brilliant I can go extract my energy
from somewhere else you know I'm not I'm
even going to leave your son alone you
know maybe I'll take a bit of mercury
but or whatever and and actually there's
this I want to give a shout out to this
to this group who are there they want to
actually build a large language model
based on human wisdom
um based on human meaning
um their their Project's going to be
called rebuilding meaning and you know
just like
yeah open AIS or other large language
models are built off sort of the Corpus
of text just available on the internet
there's they want to basically build a
large Corpus of text of
true real humans
say you know typing in like an example
of something that happened to them in
the last week or the last year or in
their lives that was meaningful so what
was you know what was the most
meaningful thing to you in in the past
week
yeah I think meeting my
um my wife's brother and and talking to
him that was meaningful to me uh cool so
imagine you then like put that into a
little you know you enter that into a
box on a website and that story is you
know anonymously captured and then you
get a million or a hundred million
people to do that you've got 100 million
copies of this of these stories and then
train a large language model on that now
that is high complexity stuff even
though it's compressed down into
language but this is so high complexity
authentically human meaningful
information that is going to contain
some amount of like a large amount of
wisdom certainly more than like your
average internet Forum or even even a
scientific paper
um because it's like truly authentic
human stuff coming from like a very deep
place
um and they want to build a large
language model of that which is a super
cool idea
um so yeah that would be a sort of uh an
example of like
how we capture human wisdom it'll be
super interesting data set to see I I
would hope that a lot of the entries
there would revolve around other people
so for example the the example that came
to mind when you asked me revolved
around another person I think I I would
predict that a large fraction would
revolve around uh people because people
like people and perhaps there's some
lesson for for uh for AIS in there all
right Liv uh thanks for coming on the
podcast it's been very interesting to me
I I hope you had fun thank you so much
yeah this is great
um really tough questions but it was
good stuff thank you